Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Last week we had
begun to discuss about the issue
regarding superstition. It is a type of
superstition
and it is very prevalent
in all times, in all places, in all
cultures.
And ancient Arabia was not exempt from
it.
And today in our society,
it is just as prevalent, if not more so,
than ever.
We were speaking about
and that is that a person
take omens.
Is when a person takes
suggestions
and makes decisions and has beliefs. Ha
has beliefs which are
all based on omens which largely are
dictated by something popular in
society. Whether that be a particular
type of animal, whether that be a
particular type of person, whether that
be a particular time, whether that be a
particular number, whether that be a
particular place, etc.
For instance, the number 13 is very
often looked at as being a very ominous
number.
Contrary, contrast and conversely,
the number seven is often looked at as
being a very lucky number and many of
these things find their roots in
gambling.
Likewise, particular animals
often have a stigma
attached to them that people believe
that this particular animal or that
particular animal
if it were to cross his path or if the
person were to see this animal or hear
it at a particular place or time or
event that this is ominous.
meaning that something bad is going to
happen, right? And it is even worse than
if a person starts to make decisions
based on these omens. If a person starts
to make these decisions based on these
omens,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala speaks about
very often and we will go into
the
way that
was viewed
and the beliefs of which were held
in ancient Arabia
to which the Messenger of Allah.
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam was sent
in order to understand
exactly what they believed
and hence understand exactly what our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said or did
in order to correct
these misconceptions and these false
beliefs and these superstitions.
Then we will inshallah
try to tie this into our common time and
place and see how it applies to us in
today's world.
Is mentioned often in the Quran. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said
And this is in
regarding the story of Mam.
When Misam was sent to
in the first part of his message and and
messengerhood,
if you will, he was sent to Fyon
and he was sent with two commands.
number one to call Fon and all of the
people under him to the worship of Allah
alone without any partners
and number two to demand the release of
Benny is from the bondage which they
were subject to at the time.
Now this was not an easy process of
course and at first
attempted to challenge Mus
directly and very publicly.
He decided that MS and his miracles that
he was provided with by Allah are but
magic tricks and that they have
magicians as well. And they're going to
and he is going to gather the strongest
the best of his magicians and they are
going to
outdo
Musam.
And so they chose a day which was a
holiday.
Fun gathered as many of us know the
story all of his might with respect
to magicians. the most skilled amongst
them.
The exact number is unknown. Some say
40, some say more, some say less. And
when Musam
threw down his stick, his staff, and it
was turned to a live snake that was able
to devour their contraptions that
they had set down and defeat their
magic.
After this,
many years went by
between this incident
and when
Musam
finally was to lead Bani out of Egypt
and which resulted in the splitting
of the Red Sea.
Now during these years
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent various
plagues referred to as plagues onto Fan
in order to try to soften
the hearts of Fan and his people to
accept the truth.
And so
they endured a number of anomalies
and a number of tragedies
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
about this that one of those was famine.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
he
sent tribulation upon them for years
of famine.
And during these years of famine, they
would have sporadic times of good and
ease and plenty.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
about how they understood
these things
because of their disbelief
because of their insistence
to disbelieve
in Musam.
Allah tells us that when something good
would happen, they would say this means
that we are doing the right thing.
whenever something good would happen
that this good thing is happening
because we're on the right path
which is one of the
first
indications that a person is upon
misguidance
is when they look at ease in this world
or they look at money or they look at
obtaining worldly things as being an
indication that Allah is pleased with a
person.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said,
he said, "Sallam,
Allah
gives wealth
to those whom he loves and those whom he
does not.
But he only gives eman to those whom he
loves." Subhanahu Wa'ta'ala.
Worldly gain is not at all an indicator
that a person is upon guidance,
that a person is upon the right path,
a person is given fame, a person is
given money, a person is given
comfort, luxury, ease.
This
does not mean that this person is
favorable to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It is what the person does with these
money and his fame and this which
determines a person's actions. Allah
gives wealth to those whom he loves and
those whom he does not. But he only
gives eman to those whom he loves.
Listen to the narration.
This is the age-old trick of a shaitan.
If you look back into history,
you look at some of the worst human
beings that ever existed.
Fan being one of them,
but many others.
The people of Tammud,
the people of Median,
the people
of Hud, the people of
you look at the people of the people of
L, the people of Ibraim and Babylon.
You look at some of the great
murderers
in history. A good example is Genghis
Khan.
Many of these people
looked at this
seeming victory,
this ease
and they would believe that they are
chosen by almighty God himself.
Genghaskhan
was one of the
most terrible
terrible human beings to ever exist.
murdered and put to the sword millions
to the point that it was said that he
affected the world's population. And not
only that, but as quickly as he was
murdering people, specifically Muslims,
he was simultaneously
having as many children as he could with
as many mistresses and wives as he
could.
It's said that a a phenomenal
a staggering amount of people on earth
today
have in them of the lineage of
Genghaskhan
because of how many children he tried to
have. Why? He was trying to
eradicate the earth's population and
replace them with himself.
And Genghaskhan thought he was a
prophet.
He did thought he was a messenger sent
by God himself.
Kind of Fon, kind of the
people of L. Kind of the people of
Ibraim,
etc. History continues to repeat itself
time and time again.
What causes this?
What causes this is
they see that Allah has given them
plenty in the earth and so they take
this as a sign that Allah is pleased
with them.
Well, if if Allah chose me to be the
great king, if he chose me to give me
all this wealth, if I'm the richest man
and blah blah blah, if I have all of
this and all of that, if all of these
people depend on me, and what would the
world do without me?
This obviously means that I am favored
by God himself.
That's what leads to this belief system.
And so Fan was no different.
Living in plenty, living in luxury,
yet his deeds were of the worst.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us in a narration collected by im Ahmed.
Listen to this narration very carefully.
How our prophet explains the world
around us to us. He says
[Silence]
chilling. If you understood that
narration, a little chill should go up
your spine.
[Silence]
for
Our prophet sallall.aii
says,
"If you see Allah
giving a man
in spite of his disobedience of Allah
of the dunya, all that he desires,
then know that this giving
is merely
a plot for this person to as they would
say you know rope for a person to hang
himself
that this is of the of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala this is of the of Allah
and so the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam tells us
that if you see Allah, if you observe
Allah
giving a man of the dunya all that he
desires
in spite of his disobedience,
then know that this is for this person
to dilute himself,
for this person to reach the depths of
darkness. ness and misguidance
to where they can never come back
because this is part of the justice of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to our
prophet Sam
[Silence]
for him.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
prophet Sam,
"And do not think that Allah is unaware
of what the wrongdoers are doing.
Indeed, he is merely delaying their
justice
until
they meet that justice on a day when
their eyes will stare
off into the distance in horror. Their
heads will be lowered,
trying to cover their heads and their
hearts
completely empty and hollow of any
thought other than black terror.
This is what Allah Subhanahu Waaala
tells our prophet sallall.aii Wasam
with respect to those who are given in
spite
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us of an
incident that occurred over a span of
many years.
It is not really any particular
occurrence that happened once or twice,
but rather it is a kind of issue
that had burrowed itself into the hearts
of some of the companions.
It's something that human beings are
plagued with
naturally.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us that
the human being is so hasty
that it could be said that he was
created from haste itself.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about
an incident
in which companions
of his not all of them some of them in
the days of Mecca in the days before
hijra
they were being abused by the mushri
they were being antagonized
they were being belittled at every turn
and junction
And so some of the younger ones amongst
them came to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
begging him to allow them to fight
to take up arms and go to battle and war
with their antagonist.
But the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
would say to them
He would say, "I have not been commanded
with what you are asking."
Rather, Allah Subhanahu Waaala
revealed to them and gave them the gift
of the five daily prayers. During this
time,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commanded them
to
for them to keep their hands to
themselves
and be concerned with your prayers and
with giving zak. Perfect this now. Keep
your hands to yourselves. This is not a
time for battle or war or fighting. Not
only would it be incredibly
inept
in this situation and this dynamic for
them to try to take up arms and have a
civil war inside of Mecca, the holiest
and safest of lands.
But furthermore, they had lessons they
needed to learn before that step was
taken.
See, people usually don't want to learn
those lessons.
They want to jump straight to the glory
days. They don't want to have the days
when they're down in the trenches with
their heads down and they are an
unknown.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, "Do you
not see to those who were told keep your
hands to yourselves and establish prayer
and give zakat?"
But then later when jihad
when fighting was prescribed for them to
defend themselves in Medina years later,
they were surprised
and they said, "Oh Allah, if only you
had NOT prescribed this upon us now, if
you just given us a little bit more
time,
why? What changed? Those same people
that were begging
for conflict, violence
in the days of Mecca. Now they got what
they seemingly wanted, but now they
don't want it. WHY DID THAT HAPPEN? WHY
IS IT that they asked for something and
then when they got it, they didn't want
it?
Because the place that that question and
request came from is a wrong place.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us of
beni is
and a similar situation.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us the
story of
and jalut
that after the passing of MS and his
brother Haronat
every time a prophet would pass away in
benel another would be appointed in his
place.
That was that was the way things were
for beni is
their scholars could not be trusted with
the books of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
unlike this this nation this mighty
majestic nation of Muhammad Sam
has one prophet one messenger and the
scholars are of such caliber and of such
esteem team that they fill that role
to its extent and they fill that role
that was only once held and filled by
prophets themselves.
After the passing of Mus Alam and his
brother Haron
Benel, their tribes leaders came to one
of their newly appointed prophets
and they SAID TO HIM, "APPOINT FOR US A
KING so that we can go to battle and
take up arms against our enemies."
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
forch.
[Silence]
He tells us subhanahu wa ta'ala THAT
THEY REQUESTED OF THEIR PROPHET APPOINT
FOR us ask Allah to appoint a king for
us to be established so that we can go
to war with our enemies and take up
arms.
And so their prophet warned them.
This is not something that came from
Allah first.
Their prophet warned them and said, "I
fear
that you requesting this before Allah
has seen it fit to prescribe upon you
that you are not going to fulfill this
command once it comes."
They said, "How could we not fulfill
this command? And we have been scattered
and driven out of our homes and our
buildings and places of residence."
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, "And so
once fighting was prescribed upon them,
they all
turned and fled except for a few amongst
them. Most of those who asked for it,
they were not involved with it at all.
This is not just fighting. This of
course is one of the obligations of
Islam.
But there in lies a deep lesson for us
all.
How do we take this and implement it IN
OUR LIVES?
NOBODY WANTS TO play the part he's been
given.
Everyone wants to jump to the glory days
first.
A person cannot be a teacher until he
has fulfilled his role as a student.
A person cannot be a leader until he has
fulfilled his role as a follower.
A person CANNOT BE A FIGHTER until he
has learned how to make peace.
These are the lessons of Allah.
We learn how to make peace before we
learn how to wage war because those are
two sides of the same coin.
And ignorance in one necessitates
ignorance in the other.
A lack of enthusiasm in ONE NECESSITATES
A LACK OF enthusiasm in the other.
AND SO WE REQUEST things because we
think that the situation we find
ourselves in now is not our fault. It's
not our problem.
THAT IF ONLY THINGS WOULD change from
the top, everything would be better. IF
SOMEONE ELSE WOULD DO SOMETHING,
everything will change. That's not how
it works.
And so this is we have this idiom in
America where we say
all Indians and no all all chiefs and
no Indians
or all roosters and no hens.
We have to first start with playing the
part that we have been given by Allah.
We fulfill that to a tea and we wait for
command from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
beyond that.
It's not just an issue of changing one
thing quickly and suddenly from the top
and everything will be okay.
This is why when fighting was prescribed
upon them they turned away. Why is that?
He says,
"Why did they turn away and not uphold
the command that they themselves asked
for? THEY REQUESTED IT. SO WHEN THEY
WERE GIVEN WHAT THEY ASKED FOR, they
didn't fulfill it." Why? Allah tells us,
he says,
[Silence]
Their prophet said to them,
Allah
has appointed for you
as your king.
You requested a king. You requested to
fight. Here is your king. Allah Allah
has appointed Taloot as your king.
Talut did not come from a wealthy
family.
He was what we would call today very
middle class.
And not only that, but he was a
tradesman as mentioned by some that he
was a blacksmith or a carpenter. He
didn't come from a wealthy family nor
was he politically connected and of high
ranking as far as chieftain goes in
tribes.
AND SO WHEN ALLAH APPOINTED FOR them
their king as Palut, THEY SAID, "HOW can
Palut be our king?
He hasn't been given the money, the
wealth of a king. He's not wealthy.
And we are more deserving of being the
king than he is."
Now we understand why they rejected it.
Why did they reject it? They asked for a
king because they thought they were
going to be the king
when the king came. And other than what
they fantasized and romanticized about
in their minds now they don't want it.
This is not what we wanted.
We wanted the king to come and be
wealthy and we were going to have
parades and we were going to scorn
our enemies and we were going to rub
their faces in the dirt and it's going
to be us and WHEN IT WASN'T THEM. WAIT,
HOW CAN HE BE given to kingship over us?
WE ARE MORE RANKFUL to kingship than him
and he's not even wealthy. As if these
are the attributes of a true king. These
are not the attributes of a true king.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
their prophet said first of all Allah
has chose him. He has chosen him above
you all. That's number one. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala does not have to
justify his decree.
But second of all, they have proven
immediately
that they are not worthy of a king. Why?
Can you imagine a general who has to
explain himself to his troops every time
he makes a decision? Could you imagine
that? I want you to post up here. Well,
why why should I post up here? Why are
we doing this over here and not this?
because all of the soldiers think that
they are they should be the general. The
general should be my soldier and I
should be his general. And so they make
very lousy soldiers. But here's the
kicker.
If a person makes FOR A LOUSY SOLDIER,
OF COURSE THEY WILL MAKE A lousy leader
because they didn't learn how to be
followers and subordinates before they
were given the entrustment of being
leaders.
They want to jump straight to the glory
days.
It's not good enough the way it is. And
so when Allah appointed their king, they
said, "We are more rightful to be the
king than he is.
Me, myself, my family, my tribe, my
leader, my this, my that, me."
And so immediately they are off on the
wrong foot
because a people deserve
leaders
and they are given leaders as they
deserve. This is a principle Allah
teaches us in the Quran.
He said the scholars tell us
as you are
leaders will be chosen from amongst you.
The leaders didn't come from outside.
THEY'RE NOT OUTSIDERS. THE LEADERS
amongst us who come from amongst us,
they are the product of our society.
It's not that they come from an alien
planet.
They come from here. It is our society
that has produced them.
And so this disease
of a person not wanting to be a
follower, everyone wants to be the king,
everyone wants to be the the the
everyone wants to be the Khalifa,
everyone wants to be the leader, all the
soldiers want to be the general. This
will make for one of the greatest
military blunders ever.
How can there be an army coherent in any
way when they have not learned
subordination to their superiors?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches us
this. And when they were not given
exactly what they had in their mind,
they abandoned it. They didn't go with
Barlut. He went to war with Jalut, but
they didn't follow him. And they
abandoned him at the first sign of
trouble immediately. The ones who asked
for him are the first ones to abandon
him on the battlefield.
It is incredibly important for us to
understand
that positions of leadership, positions
of knowledge, positions of authority,
they are only best filled by individuals
who have learned to achieve them.
Our prophet sallall.aii Wasam
tells us of the best of people
and he saidd
[Silence]
FOR
he says sah. Wasam,
the lowliest of people are the slaves of
gold and silver, the slaves of
comfortable and extravagant clothing.
They are the lowliest.
He says
the best
is for a man, a type of person, he tells
us holding the reigns of his horse,
prepared at the drop of a hat to answer
and to apply himself to any position
that Allah has deemed fit for him.
He says his hair unkempt, his feet
dusty.
If he is placed as a guard, he gives
being a guard his all.
And if he is placed at the farthest back
of the mil of the army, he gives that
position his all.
A KIND OF PERSON THAT IS SO unknown
that when he asks for leave of absence,
he is not granted.
And when he
intercedes on anyone's behalf, his
intercession is not honored.
What is the prophet telling us here?
Sall.ai Wasam positions of guarding
while everyone sleeps and you're awake
at night. It's a very thankless job.
Nobody wants that job.
Everyone wants to be the one in the very
front of the army where everybody sees
you and he's the hero.
NOBODY WANTS TO BE THE GUARD AT NIGHT
where no one sees him and there's no
action, BUT SOMEBODY HAS TO DO IT. But
this person is not there for glory. This
person is not there for mention. This
person when he is appointed as a lowly
guard. He is the best of guards. He
gives it his all in his heart because he
is worshiping Allah. Whether he is the
general or he is the guard. When he is
placed at the rear, he is at the rear
fulfilling his position to a tea.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said those people who are unmentioned
unknown
those are the closest of men to Allah.
In another narration he tells us that
those men
whom no one knows those forgotten
soldiers
those men are the first men to enter
paradise on the day of judgment. Subhan
Allah.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us that they are the first to enter
paradise.
When we look at those who pass away, who
is the only person in history that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam made janaza
upon after the person had died and been
buried.
a person that was so unknown that to
this day the scholars debate whether he
was a a male or female.
This is how unknown this person was THAT
THEY ARE STILL debated
as whether they were male or female
and this was a person who used to clean
the masid. No one know their name.
People didn't even know till today if
they were male or female. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam observed that
this person hadn't been around for a few
days. He asked about them and he was
TOLD THAT THAT PERSON DIED AND WE BURIED
HIM. He said, "WHY DID YOU NOT TELL ME?"
And he had them take him to the person's
grave. And he made salat janaza upon
them in the grave. The first and only
person he ever prayed over their grave.
Imagine that. Who was it? The nobody
cleaning the masid doing something that
no one wants to do.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
How much you miss me?
allayikum.
Just a couple of quick announcements.
The first one is there is going to be a
campfire meeting this evening for the
youth group is conducting that after
Ishan. So about 7:30 inshallah they'll
be gathering in the parking lot and
having fun inshallah please join.
also the reminder as you know the year
end is is upon us and your Arizona
tax liability can be directed towards
the Rama Academy. It helps us
tremendously and it fulfills your
responsibility. So if you do that before
the December 31st then it can apply
towards this year's taxes and if it's
you're going to be the we will be still
continuing to ask for the next year but
that will be accounted for the following
year. So if you're really interested in
taking a deduction this year, please
make sure you are giving that signing
up for that. Brother Jabar is back there
with the flyer in his hand and see
him all the way out. If you have any
questions about that, please seek him,
supply him, and he'll give you all the
answers. It is something that anybody
that owes tax liability to the state of
Arizona, whatever you owe up to the
limit that is allowed for the state of
Arizona, for the couple is close to
2,000 and for the single is half of
that. So that is something that we need
to make sure everybody knows in our
community so we could raise enough
funds.
Please donate generously for your
mustard on the way out too.
[Silence]
I'm sorry.
She was
[Silence]
Oh
South all the way south
of the nation. Thank you guys.